yet Trump Trump wants to reopen bar is
going to the states for the lock downs
mm-hmm
I don't think people come November gonna
blame Trump for this once the Democratic
governors who are insisting we stay shut
down people are complaining and the
Republican governors are the opposite
like yeah let's keep open let's open
everything such a weird world it's weird
yeah like we mentioned several times
Gallup poll showing Republicans in
Congress have more favored have higher
favorability now for the first time in
like 20 or 30 years that's crazy I tried
telling people you know it's like they
want to accuse me of being biased and
I'm like I think you just don't see
what's really going on yeah give it time
give it time give him time yeah when I
said all the things I said two years ago
right mm-hm what happens two years later
Gallup poll comes out saying Republicans
have a higher favorability why it's not
because I'm making things up or lying to
protect the right it's that the right
was was correct about what they were
doing yeah and the American people
responded positively to it mm-hmm and so
then I was like see I wasn't wrong there
you know Donald Trump's approval ratings
higher than it's ever been on average
it's it's it's going down a bit from its
highest point but still higher than it's
been on average you know his
favorability is up New York Times says
my opinion of them has certainly raised
up higher you know what it is I got to
tell you man the more they lie the more
they they they get caught lying mm-hmm
the more anger I have for everything the
media the Democrats the cronies have
done and I I can feel it you know when
you go to that voting booth and you want
to just stick it to the man by slamming
down that Donald Trump lever yeah I dude
Chuck Todd ah he's MSNBC right Meet the
Press oh yeah he put out a clip out of
context and got and got called out
immediately for it okay they used to
think they could get away with this they
played a clip of bill Barr the Attorney
General making it seem like he was
gloating that nothing like haha were the
winner so we can do whatever we want or
like okay basically he was asked about
dropping the charges against Flynn
Michael Flynn and he said well you know
history is written by the winners so
okay but he said I think history will
shine favorably showing us we filed the
rule of law they cut the last part out
so it's him laughing going like history
is written by the winners like making it
seem like yeah they used to do this
stuff but and no one no one was
go for it they were like this is BS yeah
well they do apologize shut your mouth
yep that's how bad it was good like
everyone called him out as a video game
called him out I love it yeah I think it
was really stark because Chuck Todd went
on to say well he didn't say anything
about following the rule of law or
having any kind of compression and then
somebody showed the full clip and it was
like yeah that's exactly what he said
next exactly ways a new way yeah
so here's what I here's what I see man I
see these these pundits on Twitter
mm-hmm and they put out there like it
just they just insults all day it's like
that you'll see it you'll see a comment
from a trump personality or from the
president and they'll say he's stupid
he's ridiculous he's a criminal he's
crook he's corrupt I'm like these aren't
ideas yes just you just know your
opinion and that's news what the lies
man the media lives yeah makes me
angrier and angrier and boy do I not not
want them to get away with all the
deception and the deceit and the lies
and it's really frustrating to man when
I see my friends go on like Instagram
and post stuff about how you know we
must remain locked down like the economy
is like people are so dumb they want to
save the economy oh how dumb are they
just want to make rich people you know
get richer and I'm like like no that's
happening already right it's like what
yeah it's the small businesses that are
going under now exactly so that these
like they end the supply chain right
well how do you talk to these people man
I don't know they have a set and mindset
and it's like they're they're getting
triggered in any other sense and they
just go emotional so all the logic goes
out the window you can't talk you can't
talk to people like that so I have
arranged posting on you know Instagram
and Facebook and stuff mm-hmm
where they're like these heartless
conservatives want people to get sick
and die like Elon Musk and I'm like what
do I say over Facebook to this person
I've known for years to let them know I
send a message to a friend of mine
there's like a high profile individual
thinker who was saying like no to
reopening the economy okay
and I was like the UN says 130 million
people will starve should we just let
those people die yeah no response all
right yeah because it goes against what
they believe so their trigger
and get emotional and can't you're just
an enemy to them now is it is it
possible that what's happening you know
so I've always been like both of us well
all three of us were like calm rational
logical people yeah and so we're driven
away from these hyperbolic emotional
like pointless reactions agreed yeah I
definitely am so is the right becoming a
more calm and logical place still with
its emotional reactions for sure and is
the left becoming a haven for the people
who just react emotionally I can't speak
for the right because I feel like I'm
still in the center and that's where I I
mean because I agree with both sides I
disagree with both sides so I think far
left are crazy people that I don't
associate with at all but but here's
what I mean okay
you are moderate probably left well
actually took the compass test you
you're liberal I am on the left and so
here you are talking about close to
center though right right right but
that's normal that's where like Road
rules have usually been so what I kind
of think might be happening is when
someone like you or me sees a
conservative liberal on Twitter mm-hmm
and the liberal is yelling Reid and the
Conservatives saying I humbly disagree
right which one here are my reasons
right I mean you're when you put it that
way and that's absolutely the person I
would side with so then my question is
over time will we end up seeing the
right I'm doing air quotes as to
whatever the right is be a bunch of
people calmly sipping their teen saying
whoa there I was very good so my
question about the economy has to do and
then you know Peter Johnson well let me
tell you about what I think and then Joe
Reubens like that's crazy I never
thought about them and on the Left it's
Ray
what would be to be less silly it was a
very good read by the way yeah tell it
quality I had to try and tone it down
cuz I don't want to scream I know it's
good though the the I guess the pond
trying to make is if if people who have
emotional reactions and don't care to do
research are manipulated into believing
all this fake stuff then the left will
just be people who are also waving their
arms they're going but while the people
on the right are gonna include moderates
liberals conservatives libertarians yeah
all being the right and having a wide
range of views but I mean conversation
about that's kind of what I was saying
earlier where it feels like those people
on the left that are really fading away
because they're becoming more and more
in a spotlight for one people that that
girl who screams no when Trump won yeah
he's now forever mean of just and who
wants to be that you who wants to be
that person everyone's like wow that
person is ridiculous like how emotional
that person is it's like yeah or you
could you know get political and try to
make a difference instead of just
standing there screaming no doing is
nothing the rethink isn't exact I'm
exaggerating a bit right to be fair
right I'll put it this way I have a
friend with hundreds of thousands of
followers who makes a post saying we
can't reopen the economy all it will do
is make the billionaires wealthier and
I'll sacrifice the poor people and so
there's no logic there there's no real
understanding of how the economy works
and they're incorrect lete disregard for
the science and the economics of it and
we're not backing it up I'm assuming no
just saying just saying just just saying
the government you just give us money
and wave rent that's what they said to
me and so when I respond with how will
these companies pay their employees if
you don't pay the rent like the landlord
isn't some guy like in a castle with a
crown right it's a dude in an office
who's like I've got a bunch of
properties yeah I got to pay here's my
mortgage who's my interest here's my
bills here's my groundskeeper here's my
staff here's my electrician here's my
repairman here's my you know yeah the
delivery guy how will all those people
get paid if you say you shouldn't pay
rent well the government should pay it
okay where does the government get the
money they just print it yeah okay so my
question is like your reaction has no
basis in reality exam no research you've
read no news stories you have reckless
disregard for those with
starve to death is that what the left
has become letting people starve to
death is basically like letting the poor
die and that was their argument to keep
it closed was exactly it that small
businesses are glad wait what the small
businesses are collapsing not the
corporate enterprise ray the
billionaires are making money they're
simultaneously nerds are fine right now
they're not worried that Robert Reich
guy or whatever name as that his name's
to Robert Reich or something Elon Musk
tweeted that he was boring and stupider
than that but he tweets out like
billionaires added you know 200 billion
dollars to their wealth during the
lockdown while poor people are
sufferings like there's the poor people
are suffering because you've shut their
businesses down yeah you understand so
it's like and they lost all their jobs
even if they weren't their own business
you know that now they have no jobs
there they're strenuous life the line
that they were riding now it's all
crumbled away so how do you talk to what
do we do yeah you know what man it's
crazy because I've always been really
good at communications like I did
fundraising for nonprofits mm-hmm
literally communicating with the public
to convince them and I'm at a loss for
how we deal with these people
hmm it's like how do you deal with
someone who says I believe in science
and then when you go here's a study
saying people are dying and starving to
death and mortality rate is low and they
go no and they throw in the garbage they
don't want that study yep yeah that
challenge is my belief system so I'm not
gonna listen to that or believe it and
that's what they do
yep they're like nope I'm good I don't
have to I don't have to agree with you
or argue with you because you challenged
what I believe that's scary so I'm just
gonna go the other way and ignore you
forever block it's like you know the
crazy thing about it is when I was
growing up it was the religious people
who behaved more that way yeah like I'm
right I don't care this is what's true
yeah and now it's all of a sudden you
have like there I was talking to people
about this you know notably Ben
Shapiro's philosophy because he's very
religious an Orthodox Jew but he's
libertarian so it's like he his mint is
is that his ideas kind of like all mine
my own business and practice my religion
how I want to not like that but now it's
like it's the fluting it's probably why
the Conservatives are have a higher
approval rating in Congress something
switched the left started you know you
know what I was thinking maybe it might
be hmm that it works this way with
trends too and cultures so you have
the left of like ten years ago you got
John Stewart right funny guy honest guy
great guy he called that Joe Biden The
Audacity of grope uncritically showing
Project Veritas like legitimately
showing Project fairness and praising
the work they did yeah
even though Veritas you know is you know
right leaning or whatever people want to
accuse them of yeah today it's all like
attacks and smears well here's what I
think happens you have someone like Jon
Stewart and you have a left that
actually has thought leaders medians
funny people and so all the cool kids
are involved I miss those days but so
the left was cool yeah you know Jon
Stewart was leading the charge in like a
comedic way to deliver the news to
people yeah he was great it was clever
too because people didn't care about the
news and he found a way to get people to
care and it was funny and it was
cultural yeah what do we get after Jon
Stewart Samantha bee John Oliver Trevor
Noah
that's just fake it's them lying and
making stuff up Jon Stewart was legit so
here's what I think happens the cool
people you know the skateboarders for
instance okay we're on the left because
the left was being rational and honest
when the left stopped being rational and
started attacking the thought leaders
and the thought leader started leaving
mm-hmm we lost George Carlin you know
twelve years ago yeah that was a huge
you know hit for what those saying left
was yeah Jon Stewart retires now the
cool people are watching the repo
shrieking and canceled culture and so
they're more attracted to the right
which is fun and memes leaving all of
the like a leaderless movement
essentially yeah the left has become
emotional reactive and leaderless no no
hyper like I mean look at Joe Rogan for
instance okay he says he'd rather vote
for you want to vote for Bernie you know
then he says I'd rather vote for Trump
but they call him like all right Niles
other weird stuff of course so it's like
if Joe Rogan who is a lefty pot smoking
you say they but that that gorilla feels
so small now there's just a small group
of people that's what it feels like to
me like they're just screaming and they
have a platform to scream on which is
Twitter and mainstream media even you
know it's like they're all over there
but the social media companies protect
them ban everyone else I know because
they're gonna last very looks because
they were always default yeah like Jon
Stewart was cool and valuable HBO all
these things
so the big companies are late to the
party mm-hmm they don't realize there
that you know the ad dollars are
propping up things people don't like
yeah you know hey maybe we're crazy
maybe we're gonna crumble eventually
maybe people like being in ignorant
bliss maybe we're the minority I think
that's the real Boogaloo that's gonna
happen is there it's just gonna be it's
gonna be a battle between those two
forces but they're gonna be smushed the
majority as far as what I believe is
people in the middle and on the right
looking at the left like wow they're
really crazy now this is why they hate
YouTube on YouTube when they put up one
of these stupid social justice
commercials yeah obliterated yeah they
say well the comments they disabled the
like and it's like right here of that
that's little areas and then eventually
just delete the video but but think
about what reddit does
right it starts banning the moderators
will ban a conservative post or moderate
post and so the what ends up happening
is Reddit so this is the way I was
explaining it earlier if you have a
hundred you know people 50 conservative
50 liberal that means there's a good
civil war between ideas okay it's like I
might say like I like oatmeal cookies no
chocolate chip is better and someone
says snickerdoodle and you have a
sometimes you'll see a snickerdoodle
post or chocolate chip post or an
oatmeal cookie post okay but then reddit
says we don't like oatmeal cookies
because sometimes raisins are in them so
we're gonna ban anyone who posts oatmeal
cookies that's a shame I love oh all of
a sudden the oatmeal cookie people start
leaving yeah because they're like we
don't get to hear about oatmeal cookies
anymore yeah and then all sudden
chocolate chip just like skyrocketing
and now there's no way to ever get a
post uploaded that's about oatmeal
cookies because they started removing
posts so right it becomes hyperpolarized
and people get washed into that insanity
oatmeal gate so so anyway the point is
you say like they might be trust him
they crush to make there might be small
but the institutions are propping them
up like no one in their right mind
no no sane reasonable person thinks Joe
Biden can be President but they're
losing their power like reddit is losing
their power I call you I mean kind of I
think it is I think the ranking has been
dropping a little bit that doesn't
surprise me and I'm sure the same is for
YouTube like who knows like [ __ ] shoots
now around nines is out like I don't
know if there's gonna be a competitor
people have asked you and and I know
it's because YouTube sets up
all the different things into one spot
so it's hard you know and they can
easily probably put someone down if
they're going somewhere else but I mean
it's a matter of time this is why I
think that Twitter same thing
I think they attacked YouTube so hard
because with with YouTube people who if
you click the video and then you watch
for a long time YouTube recommends it
more okay
it wasn't about an arbitrary of my
writers deleting stuff yeah so this
allowed content that people actually
like to start doing really really well
and there's been a massive spike in
conservative content at least they call
it conservative what I really think it
is it's the culture war right right I
don't think it means right-wing or
left-wing and it's a political or just
not left-right it would be more exactly
right yeah because in the in the
rankings they consider my content
conservative mm-hmm when I made I made a
video arm like the death penalty should
be opposed by all measured like at all
costs and I had a bunch of conservatives
argue with me like I disagree and I'm
like while I oppose the death penalty
yeah it's not a conservative opinion for
the most part I say for the most part
because it's a it's a particularly
libertarian position yeah but it's like
I can I can say my position and my
politics which are clearly liberal
left-leaning as are yours
yeah but because we'll rag on the left
they say we must be right so this this
kind of content is skyrocketing these
social justice racist commercials are
getting attacked left and right you know
but then you know you note it it's it's
it's almost like venture capitalists and
advertising agencies are trapped ten
years ago when they thought the left was
hit yeah I'll tell you what man yeah
that's a you're right
I have rock stars I say rock stars but
like very famous musicians really who
hit me up oh and like will be like yo
bro I saw your video man and they'll say
like here's what I was thinking
pro skateboarders I wanted I want to jam
with these people yeah sound I want to
skate with those people do the craziest
thing we I've said this before but bears
repeating in the context of this video
when I got hit up by some of these pro
skateboarders yeah
like dude skateboarders trespass they
make the rules they care for no laws or
anarchists like libertarian and they
were hitting me up being like I agree
we're not a percent like this is not
dude you know it is I think
skateboarders real
not for the most part because a lot of
probably not paying attention mm-hmm
but at the core like these authoritarian
leftists and the weird social justice
stuff it's fake social justice its
authoritarian and it's the antithesis of
skateboarding yeah
skateboarding is all about you
conquering by yourself like a
skateboarder will tell you hey man you
got to do it you got to drop in
one's gonna drop in for you yeah that's
the antithesis of what they say it's
true like you need to you need to know
someone has to drop in for you because
if your privilege is not fair or
something you're too tall you're a man
you're a woman whatever so I started
getting up hit up by skateboarders
telling me they agreed and stuff and I'm
like some people that I've known since I
was a kid and looked up to I was like
wow man like these people are hippies
like these are the leftists who are like
chillin smoking pot in the beach arguing
against the Democrats right now that to
me who's like I think I think these
marketing companies you know still just
assume the left is cool right I'll tell
you what man side note and then figure
it out they'll follow the money
well actually what we should we should
jump to the skateboarding segment in
this in this you know but I'll make one
more quick comment there was a post on
reddit about it was like FB alt right or
something okay like Isis are dedicated
to ragging on the alright which
basically doesn't exist anymore like as
a movement like this been wiped out by
social media okay but it was a it was a
picture of desmond the 11 year old drag
queen dance oka are you familiar with
the desmond story i don't think so 11
year old boy
ripping off their clothes on stage for
money as adult men throw money at him
okay I've heard about this but I never
saw the video so someone wasn't really
cringe it's horrifying it's horrible
sounds terrible like so well I don't
want to get too into detail but it's a
little boy pulling off his clothes on
stage he's wearing clothes under these
multiple layers okay
and then men throw dollars at him I
asked some people I know who have
familiarity with the gentlemen club
enterprises strippers members an ass
endure and they told me that was
stripping they said that what people
don't realize yeah about stripping is
that a lot of strip clubs don't allow
full nudity yeah so so the women where
they wear like sports bras and sport
running shorts and when they strip
they're still fully clothed underneath
okay and so I was specifically told
about that video they're like oh yeah
like in South Dakota 100% that's that's
legit stripping like that would be
considered stripping to any stripper in
like these areas in these jurisdictions
so is this who's who's okay with this
video like the tribal left so this is
the point I was getting to like where I
think things might be starting to break
maybe is that somebody was attacking you
all right posted the picture and said
something like right-wingers keep trying
to post this to attack this poor child
or something and then I looked at the
comments and the comments were all like
ah no I kind of agree that's messed up
like what the my god oh my like is this
kid dance what is this you know like
people actually saw and they were like
why this is messed up stuff put it on TV
though ain't like like these chant I
don't know what channels I want to call
them out get in trouble but the bunch of
channels are like praising this and
cheering for it yeah dude it's getting
nuts out there man my goodness so yeah I
just bring it up as the last bit of like
it's never one of the more extreme
instances thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you